สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะครูหญิงค่ะวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
26 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมค่ะปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
ค่ะค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ
2022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้ 9
น 27 นค่ะอู้ 9 นแล้วครูเรียมกินข้าวหรือ
ยังคะกินข้าวเรียบร้อยแล้วค่ะครูโหอิ่ม
แล้วใช่มยอิ่มแล้วผู้หญิงกินข้าวหรือยัง
ผู้หญิงกินข้าวแล้วค่ะครูหญิงก็กินข้าว
แล้วอิ่มแล้วเหมือนกันออครูหญิงครูหญิง
ได้ดูขาวนึงในทีวีมยหึข่าวที่ประเทศไทย
เหรอคะใช่ข่าวที่ประเทศไทยที่แบบรถชนกัน
น่ะหึไม่ได้ยินไม่ได้ดูข่าวเลยหรอมีแบบใน
Facebook นะอืที่แบบเลื่อนๆดูโหมีคนพูด
ถึงข่าวนี้เยอะ
มากที่แบบมีคนแบบขับรถไปชนคนอื่นแล้วก็
บอกบอกตัวเองว่าเอ้ยบอกคนอื่นบอกคนอื่น
ว่าผมเนี่ยเป็นตำรวจเป็นตำรวจอือใหญ่ๆเลย
นะโอเคทุกอย่างโอเค
อ๋อโอเคกร่างใส่อีกคนนึงเหรอคะครูเรียม
ใช่ๆประมาณว่าแบบอยากให้มันจบอ่ะอยากให้
มันจบชนกันแล้วก็แบบอ่ะต่างคนต่างแยกย้าย
ต่างคนต่างแยกย้ายแบบนี้มันโอเคมเหมือน
เหมไม่โอเคค่ะทำไมอ่ะถ้ารถชนก็ต้องคุยกัน
สิเออว่าเอ้อใครผิดอ่ะคุณผิดฉันผิดใช่มย
แต่ผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยเค้ากร่างอีกคันนึง
ใช่่มยเค้าแบบใช่ผมเป็นตำรวจนะเออเอ่อจบ
แล้วโอเคเอออย่างเงี้ยไม่ได้นะนิสัยไม่
ดีใช่เรียงเลยเอือแล้วเวลาคนดูข่าวก็เลยะ
ทำไมแบบมีแบบอำนาจเยอะๆใช่มยแบบมีพาเวอร์
เยอะๆอใช่แล้ว
แบบทำไมอ่ะแล้วยังไงทำไมต้อง
กล่างเออใช่แปลว่าเค้าผิดหรือเปล่าไม่รู้
ถ้าเกิดผิดก็คือผิดไงเออแต่เ้าแต่บางคน
เขาก็รู้สึกอ๋อฉันเนี่ยมีอำนาจใช่มยทุกคน
ต้องกลัวฉันอืใช่ฉันจะทำอะไรก็ได้ใช่ก็
เลยเาก็เลยกร่างใส่อีกคันนึงไงคะให้อีให้
รถอีกคันนึงอ่ะที่ชนกับเขาอ่ะกลัวเค้าใช่
มใช่ให้เค้าให้คนนั้นน่ะกลัวแล้วก็แบบไป
ก็แบบยอมยอมจเรื่องนี้เอยอมแล้วเาก็ไม่
ต้องจ่ายเงินใช่ไม่รู้เนาะเออใช่ใช่ค่ะ
นิสัยไม่มีรรู้อืออือแล้วว่าเรียมเคยเจอ
คนแบบนี้มั้ยโหคนที่นิสัยกร่างครูเรียม
เคยเจอมั้ยคกร่างหรอมีนะแต่ส่วนใหญ่ก็
เห็นในข่าวในแบบที่เราเลื่อนเลื่อนฟีดใน
Facebook อ่ะแล้วก็เจอข่าวโอหคนนี้ก็
กล่างแบบเวลาที่แบบมีคนขับรถนะขับรถขับรถ
มาแล้วก็แบบมีคนปาดหน้าแล้วบางคนก็แบบมา
ปาดหน้าสลับกันไปสลับกันมาขับรถอ่ะอือ
แล้วสุดท้ายก็จอดรถลงมาคุยกันแล้วก็มาคุย
กันรู้มั้ยพ่อกูเป็นใคร
เออคืออะไรอ่ะครูหญิงทำไมเต้องใช่ถ้าเกิด
เป็นครูหญิงมีคนมาพูดว่ารู้มั้ยพ่อกูเป็น
ใครูหญิงทำยังไงอ้าไม่รู้
ค่ะคจะตอบยาวกว่านี้เดี๋ยวนักเรียนไม่รู้
จักเออเอ่อไม่ได้อยู่ออฟฟิศเอ่อออฟฟิศ
ทะเบียนบ้านนะคะรู้จักทุกคนเออคนักเรียน
อาจจะงงไงแล้วพ่อเค้าคือ
ใครคือคือนักเรียนจะไม่รู้ว่าคนไทยอ่ะค่ะ
ที่มีนิสัยกร่างอ่ะเคชอบถามคนอื่นว่ารู้
มั้ยพ่อเป็นใครก็คือบอกคุณพ่อเค้าอ่ะ
เหมือนรู้จักคุณพ่อของเามย
อืมใช่มั้ยคนแบบเนี้ยนิสัยก่างแบบคิดตัว
เองมีพาเวอรมีอำนาจไงใช่ที่เาถามว่ารู้มย
พ่อเป็นใครเพราะเคคงคิดว่าพ่อเแบบมีอำนาจ
มีพาเวอร์เยอะๆอยู่ในแบบใชตำแหน่งสูงๆ
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยทุกคนต้องกลัวพ่อเขาใช่ทุก
คนต้องกลัวพ่อเขาเขาก็เลยต้องมาถามว่ารู้
มยว่าพ่อเป็นใครใช่ๆๆค่ะบางครั้งเราก็แบบ
เขาเป็นใครผู้หญิงก็อาจจะถามครูหญิงไปกับ
ครูเรียมใช่มยแล้วก็มีคนเนี้ยแล้วก็ถาม
รู้มยพ่อเป็นใครครูเรียมรู้มยเราเราเคย
เจอกับเ้าหรอเรารู้จักคุณพ่อเหรือเปล่า
ใช่บางคนก็พูดว่าโหขนาดชื่อพ่อตัวเองยัง
จำไม่ได้เลยเทำไมต้องมาถามคนอื่น
ใช่มยใช่ๆค่ะแต่แบบว่าใช่นั่นแหละจริงๆ
บางคนก็อาจจะไม่ได้แบบเป็นอย่างนี้ก็ได้
นะก็อาจจะมีเหมือนกับเมื่อเวลาที่เราทำ
อยู่ในออฟฟิศอย่างเงี้ยอยู่ในที่ทำงานน่ะ
ค่ะแล้วบางคนก็อาจจะอ่ะสมมุติมีบอสใช่มย
มีเจ้านายอ่าแล้วก็ครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูเรียม
ทำงานด้วยกันเนาะเจ้านายเป็นผู้ชายอย่าง
เงี้ยแล้วครูหญิงเป็นแฟนกับเจ้านายอ๋อแต่
ครูหญิงเนี่ยตำแหน่งเท่าครูเรียมนะออ่า
แต่ครูหญิงเป็นแฟนกับเจ้านายไงกับบอสครู
หญิงก็กร่างใส่ครูเรียมได้นะอือ่าครูหญิง
ก็บอกเรียมทำนี้ให้หน่อยนะอืไปชงกาแฟมา
ให้หน่อยอืใช่เพราะว่าฉันเป็นแฟนจนายนะอื
เธอต้องถ้าเธอไม่ทำใช่ฉันจะจะไปบอกเจ้า
หนายไม่ให้โบนัสอืือันนี้อันนี้กล่างมั้ย
ใช่กล่างมากอืครูเรียมเคยเป็นมั้ยคะอ้า
ไม่
ใช่ก็อยากเป็นอยู่นะไม่ใช่
สิไม่ได้มันไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีแต่ก็มีเพื่อน
นะที่แบบก็แบบเค้าเป็นคนที่แบบกล่างกล่าง
แบบที่คิดว่าตัวเองมีพลังเยอะๆคนอื่นต้อง
กลัวคือเป็นคนที่ชอบใช้กำลังอย่างเงี้ย
แล้วอยู่ดีๆเดินเข้ามาถังขยะนะอ๋ออยู่ที่
เหลี่มเราเนี่ยตอนที่เรียนอยู่ในโรงเรียน
อมีถังขยะอยู่ตนเรียนเด็กๆเหรอคะใช่มีถัง
ขยะอยู่ในห้องแล้วเเดินมาเดินๆๆๆมาแล้วก็
เตะถัง
ขยะอืเมื่อโชว์ให้คนอื่นกลัวเค้าอ่ะเหรอ
ใช่โชว์ให้ให้คนอื่นแบบกลัวแบบอย่าไปยุ่ง
กับเ้าพนี่มาแล้วเออใช่อือเงี้ยแหละเขาก็
เรียกว่ากล่างนะแบบเนี้ยแบบเดินมาแล้วก็
เตะทางขยะหรือว่าแบบทุบโต๊ะแบบเนี้ยแล้ว
คุณครูครูไม่อยู่มีเพื่อนอยู่ในห้องอู๋
อันนี้ผู้หญิงเคยมีคุณครูที่เดินมาแล้วก็
พุกโต๊ะเสียงดังๆเลยนี่คุณครูกร่างคะก็
ไม่รู้นะก็ไม่กล้า
พูดแต่ผู้หญิงก็เคยมีนะแบบครูเรียมแบบที่
โรงเรียนอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแต่ว่ามันไม่ใช่แบบ
เนี้ยเหมือนเหมือนสมมุติเราอ่ะครูหญิงกับ
ครูเรียมเนี่ยเรียนห้องเดียวกันเรา
อายุ 13 อืสมผู้หญิงอายุ 13 ครูเรียมอายุ
13 ก็จะมีรุ่นพี่อายุ 14 แล้วก็อายุ 15
เมื่อแล้วแบบเมื่อก่อนน่ะเราก็จะกลัวจะ
กลัวรุ่นพี่อ่ะรุ่นพี่ผู้หญิงอ่ะค่ะที่
เขาอายุ 15 เพราะว่าแบบเขาคจะคืออันนี้
เขาคก็ไม่ได้ถึงกับเดินมาแล้วก็ตบโต๊ะ
หรือว่าเดินมาแล้วก็เตะถังขยะอ่ะแต่เวลา
เขาเดินน่ะเขาจะเดินแบบเป็นกลุ่มใหญ่ๆอ่ะ
ค่ะแล้วก็แบบถ้าเราเดินอยู่อ่ะเค้าจะหลบ
เค้าก็จะบอกให้เราหลบอย่างเงี้ยเราก็ต้อง
แบบยอมหลบอ่ะค่ะเออแล้วหรือแบบถ้าสมมุติ
ว่ามีเพื่อนเพื่อนผู้ชายในห้องของเขาอ่ะ
ชอบครูเรียมสมมุตินะอเคก็จะเดินมาแล้วก็
แบบเฮ้ยห้ามชอบอ้าวคุณเรียมก็แบบแฉันไม่
ได้ชอบคนนั้นน่ะมิสเตอร a มาชอบฉันอย่าง
เงี้ยคือเขาคก็จะทำแบบเนี้ยหรือไม่ถ้า
เขาคไม่ทำเคก็เวลาครูเรียมกลับบ้านน่ะเรา
จะเดินกลับบ้านไงเพราะว่าแบบบางครั้งบ้าน
จะอยู่ใกล้ๆกับโรงเรียนน่ะค่ะเขาก็จะมา
ดักรอครูเรียมแล้วแล้วแบบเา้าก็จะแบบแขน
เสื้ออย่างงี้ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็จะแบบเงี้ยโถ
แขนเสื้อให้หน่อยเงี้ยแนเสื้อแล้วก็เดินๆ
ๆน่ะเราเก็จะดักรอเหมือนแบบจะตบคูเรียม
อ่ะเพราะว่าเพื่อนในห้องเค้าอ่ะมาชอบ
คูเรียมแบบน่ากลัวมากอ่ะอันนี้กร่างไวล่ะ
อันนี้กร่างกร่างมากอนใช่เตรมก็ไม่ค่อย
เห็นผู้หญิงที่แบบกล่างนะส่วนใหญ่ก็จะ
เห็นแบบผู้ชายใช่แต่ว่าพอครูหญิงอายุ 14
ปุ๊บเขาก็ออกแล้วไงเพราะว่าโรงเรียนมันมี
แค่ถึงอายุ 15 ไคะตอนนั้นน่ะเราก็จะเจอ
เขาแค่ปีเดียวเท่านั้นนะแล้วก็ไม่มีแล้ว
อุยออุยดีแต่น่ากลัวใช่ๆน่ากลัวเพราะว่า
คนที่เค้าแบบกร่างนะเค้าก็จะแบบบางทีเก็
จะพูดเสียงดังหรือว่าตะโกนเสียงดังเฮ้ยๆ
หรือว่าทำท่าทางแบบโหตัวเองตัวใหญ่มากใช่
แบบทุกคนต้องกลัวเค้าอ่ะอ่เพื่อให้คนอื่น
กลัวอืนั่นแหละคนที่แบบกร่างเวลาที่เรา
เห็นเราก็จะบอกว่าทำไมกร่างจังเลยเออแบบ
คนนี้กร่างจังอือทำไมต้องเดินใหญ่ขนาด
นั้นด้วยอ่ะอืทำไมหรออือแล้วแล้วล่าสุดนะ
ที่แบบมีงานคอนเสิร์ตแถวๆบ้านเรียมนะก็จะ
แบบมีอะไรคล้ายๆกันแบบนี้แหละที่แบบวัย
รุ่นใช่มยมาแบบมาเจอกันแล้วแบบทำตัวกลาง
อ่ะแบบค่ะชั้นใหญ่ทีเนี้ยทีเเออใช่เป็น
เป็นที่ของฉันแล้วก็แบบจะเดินแบใช่ใช่
แล้วเราก็ต้องกลัวเค้าอ่ะอืสุดท้ายก็แบบ
ตีกันอืใช่เหมือนแบบมันจะมีเออใช่มว่าแบบ
ทำตัวกร่างไงแล้วคือสมัยก่อนน่ะอย่างสมัย
ก่อนน่ะค่ะเวลาที่แบบเราเป็นเด็กอ่ะเราจะ
รู้สึกว่าอ๋อถ้าเราอ่ะทำตัวแล้วก็ทุกคน
น่ะกลัวเรามันจะรู้สึกแบบอมันมันเท่อ่ะ
มันแบบมันูอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเด็กวัยรุ่นน่ะ
เนาะเออแต่พอโตๆโตมาแล้วแล้วก็แบบมองไป
เมื่อก่อนแบบใชเออทำไป
ทำไมใช่ส่วนมาจะเห็นช่วงวัยรุ่นนะหรือว่า
ถ้าเกิดเป็นวัยทำงานเนี่ยก็จะเป็นคนที่
อยู่ตำแหน่งสูงๆเป็น CEO บางคนนะบางคนไม่
ใช่ทุกคนก็จะรู้สึกว่าตัวเอง
แบบยิ่งใหญ่มากใช่ใช่เราต้องกลัวเค้าอัน
นี้น่าจะเป็นแบบบริษัทคนไทย
เนาะเออบริษัทคนไทยใช่ค่ะแบบเหมือนเมื่อ
ก่อนน่ะผู้หญิงไม่ไม่ใช่บริษัทผู้หญิงนะ
คะแต่เหมือนกับว่าเราต้องไปแบบเราต้องไป
ทำงานที่บางอย่างที่ต้องไปคุยกับพวก
goverment  Office อ่ะค่ะอ่าแล้วเสร็จ
แล้วแบบพนักงานน่ะพนักงานของของเขตของ
อำเภออย่างเงี้ยที่ที่เป็นแบบ goverment
Office หรือว่าอาจจะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เขตไม่
ใช่อำเภอก็ได้ค่ะเป็นคนที่ทำงานของ
goverment  Office นั่นแหละหรือเราเรียก
ข้าราชการน่ะนะคะเจะแบบเาจะกร่างมากๆอ่ะ
เหมือนแบบเราต้องเราต้องยอมเค้ามากๆอ่ะขอ
นะคะช่วยหน่อยค่ะอย่างเงี้ยเหรอเราต้องไป
แบบช่วยหน่อยค่ะคือแบบอย่างุหญิงเคยเจอนะ
คะครูเรียมอันนี้ไม่ใช่ของครูหญิงนะเป็น
เหมือนคุณแม่คุณแม่เนี่ยตอนนั้นน่ะเอ่อ
คือเค้าเรียกอะไรเราเปลี่ยนบ้านใช่มั้ยคะ
อือ่าคือเรามีบ้านแล้วแบบเราไม่อยู่บ้าน
หลังนั้นแล้วเราทำเราสร้างบ้านใหม่อ่ะที่
ใหม่อ่ะเปลี่ยนที่อยู่อ่ะค่ะแล้วทีเนี้ย
พอเราเปลี่ยนบ้านปุ๊บเราคุณแม่เนี่ยเาก็
ไปเปลี่ยนบัตรประชาชนอืหรือว่า ID การด
อ่ะอ่าเขาคก็ไปเปลี่ยนใช่มยคะเพราะว่าแบบ
ที่บ้านของเราอ่ะมันเปลี่ยนแล้วไงแล้วแม่
แมู่หญิงก็เป็นคนต่างจังหวัดอ่ะคนต่าง
จังหวัดเขาก็จะกลัวแบบคนที่ทำงานในคือเขา
ก็ไม่ได้กลัวขนาดนั้นแต่เขาก็จะแบบไม่
กล้าพูดอะไรอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วมันมี
พนักงาน 2 คนอันนี้ยังไม่ได้ทำงานเลยนะ
ครูเรียมเหมือนเป็นแบบคอนแทค 1 ปีอ่ะ
เมื่อก่อนมันจะมีแบบแค่คอนแทคอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะเป็นแต่เจ้าหน้าที่อ่ะคนที่ทำไ ID
การดอ่ะโอเคพูดดีอืมอ่าคนที่เป็นแบบใส่
ชุดสีสีน้ำตาลนะสีน้ำตาใช่คสีน้ำตาลแบบ
เยบอันเนี้ยสีน้ำตาลเออใช่ใส่ชุดสีน้ำตาล
อย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็จะเป็นคนถ่ายรูปใช่มย
เป็นคนทำ ID การ์ดบัตรประชาชนให้เราอ่ะ
อ่ะโอเคพูดดีแต่ตรงเนี้ยมันจะมีคล้ายๆ
เค้าเรียกอะไรอ่ะคะ Reception หรออืมอ่า
ที่แบบเราเ้าจะเรียกคิวเราใช่เ้าจะเรียก
คิวเราอ่ะแบบยังไงคะดีมั้ยก็จะแบบว่าไม่
ดีเลยครูเรียมเด็กๆด้วยนะเด็กผู้หญิงแบบ
อายุน่าจะเพิ่งเรียนจบอ่ะค่ะแล้วเคูหญิง
จำไม่ได้ 100% นะแต่เขาอ่ะพูดกับคุณแมู่
หญิงไม่โอเคอ่ะแบบไม่ต้องเปลี่ยนหรอกค่ะ
หมดอายุแล้วค่อยเปลี่ยนก็ได้ไม่เป็นไรมัน
ใช้ได้คือคุณแม่จะไปเปลี่ยนบัตรประชาชน
แต่แบบประชาชนเนี่ยมันยังมีเวลาอีก 2 ปี
ก็เค้าคือมันไม่ต้องเปลี่ยนก็ได้อ่ะค่ะ
ครูเรียนมันใช้อันเก่าได้มันโอเคแต่แบบ
เจ้าหน้าที่อ่ะเขาพูดไม่ดีมากๆเขารู้สึก
แบบคือเาทำตัวเหมือนกับว่าเคมีอำนาจมาก
กว่าอึยคนธรรมดาเ่าชาวบ้านใช่มยแบบแต่ง
ตัวแบบอึยดูแล้วอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเออก็กมากๆ
ผู้หญิงรู้สึกใช่มยว่าเขาแบบทำตัวกลาง
ใช่่ค่ะผู้หญิงก็เลยเดินเข้าไปหาคุณแม่
กับแมู่้หญิงอ่ะแล้วก็แบบมีอะไรหรอคะว่า
ตอนนั้นู้หญิงไโตแล้วไงเ่าู้หญิงไม่ใช่
เด็กๆแล้วนะคะถ้าู้หญิงเด็กๆู้หญิงก็กลัว
เหมือนกันแต่นีุ้หญิงโตแล้วไงคูหญิงก็เลย
เดินเข้าไปถามว่ามีอะไรหรอคะเขาก็เลยแบบ
พูดดีขึ้นน่ะค่ะเอออ๋อแต่ตอนแรกอ่ะใช่
เพราะว่าแม่ครูหญิงเขาจะเป็นคนแบบแต่งตัว
สบายๆเออแล้วว่าคนต่างจังหวัดอ่ะค่ะเขาก็
จะไม่ค่อยแบบไม่ค่อยมาแบบฉันจะมาทำแบบ
ประชาชนนะอย่างเงี้ยก็ไม่มีมีอ่าอืเขาจะ
แบบกลัวเจ้าหน้าที่นิดหน่อยเงี้ยใช่ใช่
ไม่ค่อยได้คุยกับคนคนอื่นน่ะใช่ใช่ค่ะคุณ
หิงก็รู้สึกก็อันเนี้ยก็น่าจะกร่างเหมือน
กันนะเหมือนแบบคิดว่าตัวเองอ่ะทำงานใช่ม
ออฟฟิศทำงานดีกว่าคนอื่นคนอื่นอาจจะแบบ
เอ่อขับวิน
มอเตอร์ไซค์ปลูกข้าวอย่างเงี้ยก็แบบรึรู้
สึกอีชชันเรียนหนังสือมากกว่าอย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะอเขาก็จะแบบใช่เจะกราบดีกว่าอะไรง
เงี้ยฉันเก่งกว่าทุกๆคนต้องกลัวต้องกลัว
ฉันใช่ค่ะนั่นแหละก็จะแบบเจอบ่อยๆแต่ตอน
นี้ไม่ค่อยมีแล้วนะเพราะว่าเราสามารถที่
จะถ่ายวิดีโอใช่แล้วก็ส่งไปคอมได้แต่ก็มี
ไงที่แบบมีคนถ่ายวีดีโอนี่แหละคนอื่นก็
เลยเห็นแบบใน Facebook ในอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
ที่เขาแชร์ๆกันมาก็ใช่ค่ะคนนี้กลางอืใช่ๆ
ๆผู้หญิงก็จำได้นี่แหละอือแบบรู้สึกแบบ
โอ้แล้วพอเวลาผ่านไปแบบ 2 ปีมั้งแม่ไปทำ
อีก 1 ครั้งก็ไม่มีแล้วนะคะทุกคนน่ารัก
มากๆอใช่อืไม่กร่างเหมือนเมื่อก่อนยิ่ง
แบบเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนคิดว่าครูเรียมก็
น่าจะเหมือนกันมเวลาครูเรียมเด็กๆอ่ะเรา
ไปแบบพวกอำเภออย่างเงี้ยค่ะจะไปทำบัตร
ประชาชนน่ะเจ้าหน้าที่จะกร่างมากๆอ่ะเรา
อ่ะก็จะกลัวมากๆใช่เราก็รู้สึกกลัวนะยิ่ง
ตอนเป็นเด็กเหมือนที่ครูหญิงบอกนั่นแหละ
นิมก็เฮ้ยกลัวแล้วเราก็อยู่แบบนี้มาตั้ง
นานเลยนะจนแบบเราโตขึ้นโตขึ้นแล้วเรารู้
สึกว่าเราเท่าเทียมกันมากขึ้นเราก็เลยรู้
สึกว่าไม่กลัวคนที่ทำตัวกลางก็เลยแบบเรา
รู้สึกว่าแปลกๆมีน้อยมาก
อือใช่แต่แบบตอนที่เราเป็นเด็กเจะรู้สึก
ว่าอ๋อเค้าอ่ะเรียนหนังสือบางครั้งเคจะ
คิดเค้าเรียนหนังสือมากกว่าเราใช่มั้ย
เค้าทำงานดีกว่าเราเขาก็จะกร่างแบบชชั้น
จบพีดีนะชั้นดอกเตอร์นะอย่างเงี้ยเค้าก็
จะก่างใส่อือืเวลาดูทีวีอย่างเงี้ยหรือ
ว่าดูคลิปที่ครูเรียมบอกว่ามีคนถ่ายมาใชม
ก็ดูแล้วก็แบบอืเจะเดินเข้าไปหยิกหูคุหิง
เวลาเห็นคน
กลางนี่เวลาดูนะคะแต่เวลาเจอจริงๆก็ไม่ทำ
อะไรเจอก็เฉยๆก็แบบเฉยๆแค่แค่แบบดูแล้วก็
เฮ้อดูเจะรู้ตัวบ้างมั้ยอะไรเงี้ยใช่ดู
ใช่ค่ะแล้วดูแล้วก็คิดว่าอู้
2022 แล้วยังมีคนที่กร่างแบบนี้หรอยังมี
คนที่เหมือนครูเรียมบอกอ่ะยังมีคนที่ถาม
ว่ารู้มยว่าพ่อเป็นใครครูหญิงคิดมันแบบ 50
ปีที่แล้วอ่ะมัน
โอเคแต่ตอนนี้ใช่มย 20222 มันรู้สึกแบบ
ยังมีอีกหรอคนนิสัยแบบนี้เออจริงๆแบบถาม
แบบพ่อกูเป็นใครหรือว่าแบบถามว่ารู้มยว่า
ฉันคือใครอ้าวเออแบบนี้ก็มีนะแบบอ้าแล้ว
คุณคือใครใช่ค่ะเอ่อคุณคือใครคะฉันคือครู
สอนภาษาไทยค่ะบอกเ้า
ไปงงไงเอยากให้รู้ว่าแบบเค้าตำแหน่งใหญ่
คนทุกคนรู้จักอะไรอย่างงี้เอใช่ๆๆเค้าก็
จะเดินแบบนักเรียนจะอาจจะเคยเห็นก็ได้นะ
แบบคนที่เดินแบบตัวใหญ่ๆอ่ะจริงเดินแบบ
เดินอย่างเงี้ยอย่างเงี้ยใช่มั้น้องเรา
เรียมตลกนี้ก็เป็นแบบใช่ค่ะมันตลกอ่ะเออ
ก็เป็นคนที่แบบกร่างเนาะหรือว่านิสัย
กร่างใช่มั้ยคะซึ่งมันไม่ดีนะไม่ดีใช่มย
เพราะจริงๆแล้วยิ่งตอนนี้เนาะทุกคนก็เท่า
กัน
ใช่
นี่ใช่ค่ะอืสำหับวันนี้นักเรียนก็ได้รู้
เรื่องนี้ถ้าเกิดเห็นใครแบบใชเป็นแบบนี้
ก็จะรู้แล้วว่าอ๋อเค้ากรางอืมายก็ไม่ต้อง
ไปยุ่งนะคะไม่ต้องไปแบบสนใจก็เอดูแล้วก็
คิด
อืแล้วก็เดินออกไปนะคะไม่ต้องไปสนใจเขใช่
ค่ะค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะครูหญิง
ใช่งั้นเรา 2 คนก็ต้องไปแล้วได้ค่ะครู
หญิงเริ่มกล่านะคะใช่ค่ะรู้มั้ยพ่อเป็น
ใครรู้มั้ยรู้มยต้องไปแล้วอ่ะหมดเวลาก็
ต้องหมดเวลาใช่ค่ะใช่หมดเวลาแล้วก็ต้อง
เลิกสอนอ่ะรู้มั้ยใช่ค่ะไปแล้วค่ะครู
เรียมสวัสดีค่ะค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ